mais radio plus bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation sur rt
france pour le disais donc vive
polémique après cette campagne de
conseil de l'europe comment est-ce que
ça a été observée depuis la turquie est
ce que ça a réagi en fait je peux vous
dire vraiment y'a pas une réaction très
grand mais chez les islamistes ou bien
ces médias qui sont proches de partir du
président arrogant il y avait une
réaction par exemple il ya un député qui
s'appelle a qu'un tube aujourd'hui il a
dit que en fait avec ses tresses avec
cette réaction les candidats
présidentiels de la france ils font une
rusticité une politique populiste et il
a partagé un petit vide de l école en
disant voilà et c'est une seule et est
contre l'islam par des candidats
présidentiels de la france mais parce
que c'est une question extrêmement
sensible des cons
on parle dès qu'on attaque évidemment ce
droit de porter le voile en france la
cure qui réagit de façon souvent
épidermique
pourquoi précisément parce que déjà le
voit c'est c'est un sujet qui a déjà
utilisé par le par le président à
redorer un camp de pise sa vie politique
et c'était toujours un sujet qui a
utilisé ça en fait avant qu'il était
premier ministre il y avait elle c'était
pas possible en fait entrer à
l'université pour les femmes qui portent
ce voile donc lui il a fait une campagne
électorale en disant quand je suis au
pouvoir voilà la femme qui porte le
voile il peut entrer à l'université il a
fait ça donc un toujours c'est un sujet
sensible pour lui et pour ce porteur de
son parti mais c'est pour ça s'il ya
quelque chose il fait une réaction
le président r douanes vous l'avez dire
puisque le valais le voile était
interdit à l'université comme en france
d'ailleurs avant avant l'arrivée au
pouvoir de du président r douanes le
président erdogan qui a beaucoup fait
parler également en turquie qu ce qui a
un peu éclipsé aussi cette cette
campagne du conseil de l'europe et non
pas encore parce que en fait si vous
voulez maintenant le sujet plus
important en turquie c'est l'économie et
aussi la santé d'arbres 1 il ya des
rumeurs comme lui il est vraiment très
malade et que c'était donc cessons de
deux sujets mais à mon avis si ils
voient que voilà il ya une réaction
comme ça contre le voile et en france il
tout de suite il veut utiliser mais je
pense que peut-être il avait pas du
temps pour effet une réaction il est
malade le président hier douanes je sais
pas il ya des rumeurs et
par exemple juste sur twitter il y avait
1 h tech en 10 ans était hier en disant
voilà lui il est mort donc à cause de ça
le président communication du président
et lui il a dû il a dû faire partager
une vidéo qui montre que ardouin il
marche très bien
notamment il marche donc il ya toujours
un regard sur sa santé on connaissait sa
proximité avec les frères musulmans
notamment il y a quelques années qui
sont pointés du doigt notamment dans une
enquête de l'hebdomadaire marianne comme
et étant influent au sein l'ue du
conseil de l'europe qu'en est il
mais je suis pas sûr les frères
musulmans ils ont pas je pense qu'ils
n'ont pas pouvoir d'influencé sur
commission a toujours des associations
mais à mon avis c'est pas vraiment je
pense qu'ils l'ont pas pouvoir de
influence sur l'europe comme ça
directement c'est à l'europe attention à
ces le conseil de lancer d'europol dont
la turquie fait partie vie mais je pense
qu'ils ont pas assez pouvoir jeu c'est
vrai que par rapport des associations il
peut essayer d'influencer mais je pense
pas que raison à ses pouvoirs comment
vous l'avez perçu ou 7 ce clip de
promotion pour la diversité et je pense
que c'est une faute c'est une faute de
communication je comprends qu est-ce qu
il essaye de faire mr même temps bâle en
dix ans la liberté d'un hidjab je trouve
que c'est un peu c'est bizarre je trouve
c'est bizarre mais après il je pense
qu'il faut essayer de comprendre
l'intention de conseil d'europe en fait
alors la turquie qui est aussi un état
laïc depuis 1920 dans un pays où l'islam
un point très important
comment est ce que vous observez la
différence de notion de laïcité pour la
turquie la france
en fait selon la constitution la turquie
ça un pays laïc mais un pratiquer
non malheureusement pas donc il ya des
différences nous avons une institution
de l'état qui contrôle en fait un peu la
religion aux pales dit annette et aussi
ils ont des imams qui contrôle des
mosquées mais médiane est en voie d
imams
aux pays étrangers et c'est bon c'est
pas vraiment même expérience de la liste
le port du voile en turquie ne fait pas
débat évidemment puisque s'est défendue
par le président r douanes néanmoins ace
que
une islamisation de la société est
perceptible depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir
du président r douanes entités vie et
non parce que vraiment et lui il qu'il a
changé système d'éducation un peu et
donc il y à des lycées qui qui produit
des des immeubles mais maintenant en
passant ces lycées vous pouvez faire ce
que vous voulez vous pouvez être
ingénieur docteur tous s est aussi une
c'est aussi une carte de liberté en fait
quand il est fait ça mais après à mon
avis je pense que avec
avec le pouvoir des islamistes en fait
les gens ils ont perdu leur conscience
sur la religion parce que c'est ils ont
vu de corruption et qui qui sont faits
par des islamistes etc donc il ya aussi
un conteur et dr merci beaucoup verra le
caucus demain soir apportez votre point
de vue sur cette question un sensible en
france merci beaucoup